la dette les déficits préoccupe une
majorité de gens sondage crop radio
canada réalisée en début de campagne
révèle que 77 % des québécois sont
inquiètes d'état des finances publiques
avec le vieillissement de la population
je pense qu'il va y avoir tellement
sorties de fonds que je vois pas comment
qui vont arriver ça craque et le parti
québécois promet d'atteindre l'équilibré
en misant sur un contrôle très serré des
budgets de limiter la croissance globale
des dépenses à 2 % par année
c'est très ambitieux pour reprendre les
termes du vérificateur général mais en
promettant à la dernière minute
d'utiliser d'éventuels surplus baisser
les impôts le pq vient de briser l'
équilibre de son cadre financier estime
ce professeur de l'université de
montréal
c'est pas dans le cadre financier alors
qu'à dans le music de budget c'est quand
finira si sur les deux seules les
premières mme marois c'est plus vrai aux
yeux de nos experts les libéraux prêche
par un excès d'optimisme en misant sur
une accélération de la croissance
économique pour équilibrer les finances
j'ai l'impression que le parti libéral
n'a pas vraiment compris que on s'en va
vers une ère où la croissance devrait
être faible et on pourra pas changer ça
tellement québec solidaire croit de son
côté pouvoir financer une longue liste
de nouveaux programmes en taxant
davantage les riches et les institutions
financières
si on était
on est dans la merde baltique quatre
portes la suède puis la fin est la honte
probablement que ça aurait dû bon c'est
parce qu'on serait relativement isolée
du nord
si vous montez fortement les impôts même
si c'est pour des bonnes choses les gens
vont soit faire leurs achats ayant soin
de se déplacer à mais vous avoir un
impact négatif accepté comme du côté de
la cac
l'essentiel de la stratégie repose sur
d'importantes compressions un exercice
toujours difficile à accomplir
le problème c'est que quand tu fais une
certaine réingénierie de l'état ça se
fait port extrêmement rapidement et très
souvent ce qu'on a noté quand on essaie
de le faire trop rapidement on n'a pas
de résultats escomptés
et comme la carte promet de remettre
toutes les économies réalisées au
contribuable en baissant les taxes et
les tarifs
il sera plus difficile de s'attaquer à
la dette ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal